but I don't think that's the way it
tends to work personally from my own
experience of working the BBC I think
it's it's simply a matter of often
reacting to events and whether the
guidelines themselves are sufficiently
robust or clear and need a certain
amount of Revision in a world of social
media and 24-hour news and all the rest
of it I I think there's a case for that
so um no I think they've made these
decisions in the way they thought best
but on the hoof against an awful lot of
pressure the political heat hasn't
helped from all sides because it's a bit
of a football this isn't it sorry to use
a metaphor and um I don't think it's
helped people think or act particularly
clearly but I'm sure it can be resolved